so in your division was like you said
city of vice astative
um
i guess special
he's very special so that would be my
other guy that you asked earlier who i
enjoyed watching and that was a guy i
again it was kind of after the fact
because
it was hard to access footage but he was
a lot of fun to watch what do you think
made him great
uh a lot of people talk to about him as
potentially one of the great
greatest ever absolutely i mean six and
so he won six and three six worlds nine
uh six worlds three olympics nine total
which there's only one or two people
above that um
so again it was it was hard to watch any
live footage of him but from what i've
seen his his feel is different he was
just ahead of his time and the feel and
the touch he had for certain moves and
different things because obviously
physically he's kind of unimposing he's
um
you know taller and skinnier which is
you know it it can work in wrestling but
it is by
less represented
um yeah he was special so good
do you uh take any inspiration from
let's talk about dagestan in general
what do you think makes those wrestlers
great yeah it's fascinating um have you
read the book the talent code
yeah it's great and that kind of talks
about these talent hot spots all around
the world so now obviously with our
wrestling academies we try to take some
lessons from that and apply it i got to
assume they didn't cover dagestan in in
that book specifically but i got to
assume a lot of the same principles
uh that are in that book apply to
dagestan and wrestling right they did
south korea and
women's golf did curacao in baseball
right they picked a lot of these other
places that were really elite
i think maybe moscow and women's tennis
also
um
so
i think all these things that make any
group great organization is probably the
same things that's happening there well
the hardship i mean what for is there
something specific about wrestling that
can
create so many great champions is it
from that area so obviously they're all
they all
love like it's a big deal that wrestling
is specifically is a big deal there you
know they do also obviously um so
that's part of his a lot of the kids are
doing it they obviously are rough tumble
tough life a lot of fights and then i
think that also that a lot of them it is
a way out right there the the
elite level athletes in that part of the
world from my understanding are really
well compensated compared to
what the average person makes and they
feel really well so people see it as a
way out whereas like and then honestly
if
america's getting better but in 2008 the
reason i went to mma was because
i didn't want to be poor my whole life
yeah you know what i'm saying it sucks
it's like well i don't want to make 20
000 for the next
48 years so i'm going to go do something
else if i could have made even and i
need to be rich right if i could have
made a hundred thousand dollars or
seventy thousand dollars wrestling i
probably probably kept wrestling um so i
think i think it's those factors i and
obviously now they have a really like
uh a bunch of really good people in one
area so it's probably and it's been
going on for a long time so there's
probably been a bunch of like adults and
coaches that are coming back and helping
that progress so yeah a lot of those
things that happen so i'm definitely
going to travel there as i talk to him
because i can speak russian it makes it
makes it very um
makes me uniquely qualified
to uh
my brother can speak a little bit of
russian your brother can yeah
okay like a little bit like two squares
and no no no like he would
oh man don't don't make me oversell i
think he would be able to have a
conversation with you i think okay
okay probably not like you what's the uh
what's the reason he knows right he i
don't know why he got obsessed with
languages and so his college degree is
actually
um
what do they call inner discs where you
have three minors who had a minor in
russian a minor in
a spanish and maybe japanese
i'm messing up it's definitely russian
and spanish are for sure i don't know
what the third one is no but yeah
it's it's really fascinating but the the
uh the emphasis on technique the lighter
drilling like they don't really go super
hard yeah and i only spent a couple so i
was there i was in vladikovkaz in 2008
that was where the world cup was we had
to train there for like two days
afterwards so um
i didn't get to dig deep did
dig deep into what was going on or
anything but yeah i mean
i think sparring has a sparring is very
beneficial for wrestling um
not like sparring mma is we fight right
sparring in wrestling is so i always
just describe it to be really simple
uh if we're drilling it's relatively
zero percent resistance if we're going
as hard as we can that's a hundred
percent there's all this gray area in
the middle that's sparring right and so
you know if you have a good relationship
like you know especially cause me and my
brother we could just go and we we know
where each other's at we don't have to
talk about it right but like in my
wrestling club i'll say okay hey i want
you guys to go 50 in this position or i
want the high crotch guy i want him to
shoot and this is for him so i want him
to go 70 and defensive guy i want you to
go 40. so you're not you're not supposed
to be trying to win here you're going to
go later i want you to give it give them
some looks you know um so i think i
think it has really taken hold in
america i think it's very beneficial for
success and i think that's
i mean america is doing better than
we've ever done
you